Oh
Hello Hello, hello, hello, hello Hi, hi, hi
Howdy duty welcome in We're gaming.
We're gonna game with my brain.
We're braining.
We're gaming and braining.
Yay!
Well, you know, I, um, I am traveling, uh, starting
tomorrow.
And so this is my last stream for, for, for now, uh, until
next week.
Um, I'll still be streaming just a few less streams, but
also there will be portals.
to to keep you company just a little less streams in March
so sorry forever don't jinx me what if what if I what if I
what if I yeah what if I like fulfill my ghostly what's the
word the thing holding me back and then I go to heaven.
Yeah, don't joke.
No, Minky for two weeks.
No, I didn't say that.
I don't know where you guys get that idea from.
I don't mind if you guys joke about it, but some people
actually believe you and think that I'm not streaming.
But I am.
And I'm doing my best.
I'm doing my best to stream.
And I also gave you...
I also recorded things for you.
So quit your whining.
Quit your whining.
We'll just summon you back.
Gotta say your name three times.
Minto juice.
Hope you have fun on your trip.
Minto.
What is a biddle-dittle?
What is the X?
You're not streaming now.
Who is this imposter?
Who is she?
Thank you so much for that gift.
Sad to hear you won't be around for my birthday.
I know you'll be working hard for all of us to do your best.
How do you know I won't be around unless it's one of the
days that portal is scheduled?
And yeah, I'm not there for your birthday.
I'm sorry, but happy early birthday!
Outer heaven.
We'll create our own heaven.
You're not real.
I took my meds.
I took them.
You're not real.
Thank you so much for the podcasting.
Ghosty brain go...
Take your time.
Your health is important.
Yeah, I need a couple days for sure after this week to at
least rest my voice for a little bit, so...
March is very busy.
I got my collab cafe.
I got my 3D live thing with my mama, a yummy mama.
So...
Happy Mind Sweeper Minto Day.
This week is my brother's birthday.
If possible, can I get a happy birthday to send to him?
Happy birthday!
I don't know your brother's name.
Hello, Minto and Ibu's like, you don't worry about us, but I
do hope you can manage some good rest in your trip.
Well, it's not a vacation, sadly, so it's very, very,
probably not a lot of rest.
Not much rest at all.
back very tired i'm not gonna lie but um you know it is what
it is i will eventually take a trip where i don't stream
maybe but then what what game should i have a daily let's
play of for that uh a week about i have a thing for like a
week What game do you guys want to see that?
I have a, like, hold on.
I have a list.
Some games that people suggested to me.
Well, Legend of Zelda is kind of long.
I don't think I could do it in like...
In seven parts.
I've been...
I've been watching the new Resident Evil.
Like, people playing it.
Since last night, I was watching people.
Why did I get to?
What's your name?
Got... Grace?
Has anyone played it yet?
It's been fun.
Yeah, Requiem, the new one.
Not spoiling myself yet, yeah.
Yeah, I was watching with Tara play it last night.
Did I ever play Outer Wilds?
I have.
Yep, yep, yep.
And I have the DLC that I've done on my channel.
Unfortunately, I had played the first Outer Wilds before.
before coming back so it's not really a game you can replay
unfortunately I have um maybe bio is Bioshock 2 kind of sure
I don't know TTIOF it's kind of a wild week for me hope your
trip goes well thanks Marilyn hope you get some rose this
week Oracle of Seasons, Ages.
I love Oracle of Seasons, Ages.
Played earlier is Combat.
I'm waiting to stream that.
I want to stream it.
Hmm.
Bioshock Bioshock 2 is about the same.
So, probably not that I could do.
I'll think of something.
I'll figure it out.
I'll figure it out i'll figure it out bio talk shoe bio talk
the bio shock podcast
i saw someone like post a clip it showed up in my timeline
about like the bio shock twist which first of all i did not
know that the game had a twist and then also I didn't, like
people were, in the comments were like, oh my gosh, this is
like one of the greatest twists of gaming history.
You're a suit.
Rest in glitch race, thank you!
Congrats on making it through Heck Week.
I got mine done too.
Yay!
Don't you dare go into the light.
They don't have idols or old man combat.
Yeah, we are nothing cool.
I cast Song of Rest, safe travels, and hopefully easy time,
even if it's a good time.
work thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you bio
hawk toa don't say that don't say that it's 2026 we left
hawk toa behind last in the 2025 but you know there was like
that one time that they were doing the girl when which she
had her like crypto coin right and they were doing a twitter
space and they were talking about I don't remember I think
it was like something about how it's not a scam and she's
like hey guys I hate to interrupt but I'm gonna go to bed
and I'll see you tomorrow and I think I quote that maybe
every day of my afterlife it's
so funny she's like good night y'all going to bed she sounds
like bart simpson when she does it so yeah that she left for
six months i love i say it to like my cats i'll be like hey
guys i hate to interrupt but i'm gonna go to bed and i'll
see y'all in the morning or whatever she says
I love quoting it.
It's so funny.
I don't even know anything about her except that.
How did they respond?
My cats?
Oh no, the people in the Twitter space?
Oh yeah, they were like, okay.
Oh my god.
It's so funny.
Oh no, how do my cats respond?
They just stare at me.
I don't care.
They react the same exact way that they reacted to her
saying that.
It sound like butters from South Park?
Oh my gosh, what does butter say?
Oh, hey, hey, Carmen.
Hey, hey.
No, I don't sound like butters.
Hey, Carmen.
Hey, hey, hey, fellas.
I must say your jazz concert was very jazzy!
As a jazz lover, I'm happy how you girls bringing it back.
Snassy gig!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Sound like Kenny?
That's like Kenny doesn't have a voice.
Kenny's like...
.
I distinctly remember Mint getting jump-scared in oblivion
and making a sound almost exactly like Butters.
What?
Perfect.
I think he's voiced once or twice.
I don't watch so much South Park.
Or, I guess, maybe like the, not the earlier seasons, but
like the mid-seasons, you know?
Oh my god, you killed Kidd.
Jenny!
Oh crap, crap, crap, crap, crap, crap, crap.
Who is a boom howler?
Oh, King of the Hill.
I've never seen King of the Hill, I'll be honest.
It's one of those shows that I wanna like, you know, kind of
sit down and get through the entire show, you know?
I think it's the kind of humor that I would like.
From what I understand, it's, like, pretty dry, right?
Or not, maybe?
I don't know.
Good comfy show.
I do want to watch it, though.
Very dry, incredibly dry?
Oh, yeah, baby.
Exciting.
Texas slice of life I love American anime let me I'm putting
on my socks okay
there's a JP dub mmm Bobby son Bobby son Shukuda yo Yana say
do your homework
ain't Josu.
Hank has a half-Japanese brother.
I can't tell if you're Josh and me, if you're pulling my leg
or not.
They have sub-dub arguments about it!
Wait, is it like...
Oh yeah, is it like Japanese fans?
Japanese fans argue over whether the sub or dub is better.
You know, I...
I...
don't really watch anime dubs there are a few that I have
watched in my afterlife time but for the most part I
probably can count on like two hands how many I could I have
watched you know like I think honestly it's like everything
that was on like adult swim at the time you know what I mean
but
honestly it's kind of like I like I So because I never
really watched outside of the dubs, I never knew how popular
they were.
Like, how, you know, like, sometimes people will, like, you
know, like, that sometimes people will be like, oh, yeah, I
can't really, like, like, I'll want to watch, but I need to
concentrate on something else, so I put on the dubs.
Things like that, I don't know.
I was just like, whoa, oh my God.
There's some that are decent, decent, and if I'm gonna watch
as background noise, I can.
but I'm just so used to reading subs anyway.
I turn subtitles on for everything.
You know what I mean?
Like, anything.
Because I want to be able to, it helps me focus first of
all.
It helps me focus with with what I'm watching and comprehend
it and everything.
So, I turn it on all the time.
Yeah.
Not everyone is into reading subtitles, which is fair
enough.
Oh yeah, yeah, for sure.
I get it, I get it But I was just like, you know Because I
was so Into Only watching subs And I wasn't like a Eww, ew,
dubs Kind of, you know, kind of ghost But I was just like I
just never knew how big the scene was Kind of, you know,
it's fun
Even for Ingureshu That I put on subtitles Oh yeah Yeah,
yeah, like all the time.
Yeah, yeah.
I'd watch a dub with Minky's voice.
I've thought about, like, what if I...
What if I, like, wanted to become...
But the thing is, is it's like, if I wanted to become an
English voice actor, I...
I'm watching Japanese.
I'm...
I don't think I'd watch my own dub.
I don't I would No I think if I were to become a voice actor
I would really want a voice in like a game and stuff I don't
know It's a little different than Than like an anime or
something Hmm
Plenty of actors don't watch their own work I guess that's
true My voice acting arc It's begun
A Chikawa character?
I'll voice Chikawa and I just make like noises.
You watch your own streams?
No.
I don't have time for that.
I don't have time to watch my own streams.
Okay.
We can keep yapping and we can also play game.
I'm gonna go for the corner.
One.
Vito dub is real.
Does YouTube letting messages through properly?
No, they should be.
They said it was fixed.
I don't know why I feel like voicing in a game is different.
I'm gonna press in the middle.
Who?
I'm getting so unlucky.
Press.
Come on.
It seems like the fix held.
Yippee!
It's over before it begun.
I feel like I maybe have a bit of a range, but I also am
like, you know...
Like, for example...
There's like some...
I feel like there's certain...
People that...
And this...
I think it's just...
It kind of sucks.
But like, there's certain people that...
You can't get into their character because of...
Who it is voicing them.
You know what I mean?
like or the actor like for me Keanu Reeves I just see Keanu
Reeves and then like with Dispatch it was like Moist
Critical or whatever you just hear him you know hmm
yeah so I'm like I wonder if like you know like I said I
have a bit of a range I feel but if I were you know a
character that sounded like me if people would just be like
oh That's just meant phantom.
One person though!
Troy Baker.
That guy is so good.
Troy Baker, oh my gosh, barely the fact that you just said
Troy Baker.
That's crazy.
I think he's so good.
Matt Mercer?
Yeah, he's really good too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna click again.
What the heck?
I'm getting so unlucky.
Okay, okay.
Um...
The Nicholas Cage effect, I get it.
I think it's just like, when the actor becomes more...
I mean, I don't know, it's hard to say.
It's not that they become more iconic.
No, no, no, no.
Oh yeah, Steve Blum, yeah!
I don't know, just there's certain actors that I see and I'm
like, oh, I just only see the actor.
I don't see like you acting.
I don't know.
It's kind of hard to describe.
Okay, let me reset.
Corner.
Boom.
Oh, we can work with this.
We can work with this.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, do you see that?
Oh, I have it cropped a little bit.
The last layout was a bit terrible.
It was so unlucky, you know?
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
We're good.
So I'm good here.
All right.
Now I have to start, like, getting my brain back into the
swing of things, right?
Oh.
Swing of things.
Time to lock.
in.
Troy Baker voiced jazz and transformers fall of Cybertron
and he sounded ridiculously close to Jazz's VA from the 80s
who was an actual jazz music.
Wait, that's so fun!
I'm told from a reliable source that the first click being
in the middle clears more space more often since mines are
generated after the first guess.
Whoa, they are!
I didn't know when they were...
Well, I wonder if it's also for this website then.
And this is 1-2, so this is safe.
And this is also...
There we go, that's safe.
And this is safe.
And then all around this one would be safe.
Min-tao, Kyoto!
Corners are still...
Statistically always better.
That's what I've said.
I've been saying this.
Website in here.
I thought Minto was still rocking XP.
No, did I fool you all?
Were you fooled by my fake desktop?
There is a video of art with you with a chainsaw back when
you're saying break stuff.
That image always looked like a great anime.
See to me.
I'm glad you think that.
This is safe.
So these, wait.
Yeah.
One, two, three, four.
Like so.
And this is safe.
This is safe.
Ohamito!
She
played us like a damn fiddle.
I still can't believe how much like...
How many references are Metal Gear references?
Crazy.
Hmm.
remember left plus right click
so many you never realize before you play the series it's
kind of funny because like the alert sound has like gone
viral or it's like yeah it's gone viral on well I guess well
rather I guess a better word would be like it's been
popularized by like quote-unquote normie media so I hear it
almost every single day of my afterlife you know I hear the
alert sound from people's phones at work I know it's crazy
it's crazy map allows you the middle click let's see if it
works here well I don't think I have anything that do I have
I don't see anything that I can clear out with like a middle
click or a right click one
two one is clearable this here it's
left click on the numbers on this site the mind sweeper dot
online site the 422 on the bottom is safe the square under
the second two is safe this one how do you know
Okay, hold on.
I'm processing this real quick.
Hold on.
I'm processing.
Let me process it.
Like, I get it, but at the same time, I'm like...
I get it, but at the same time, I'm like...
Because it's like... I get that...
Okay, let me explain.
I'm not looking at chat.
I'm trying to explain in my own words so I can understand.
I get that one of these has to be...
be has to be a bomb and then it's something where it's like
well you can't have this spot be a bomb because then it
would be a three instead of a two and things like that but I
still don't understand how you know you are correct I
understand the process, but I don't understand how you know
what one is the right one.
Google the one-to-one pattern.
I'll do that.
Actually, that's a good idea.
I need a visual.
One-to-one pattern.
Oh my god, it's literally giving me graphs.
Oh, never mind.
It's giving me the one-to-one harmonic pattern 4x training
for profits.
Oh my god!
No!
I don't...
What is this?
Oh my god.
I need to...
Oh.
I don't...
I need to put in Mind Sweeper.
It's trying to...
It's thinking I'm an actual smart person.
Okay, hold on.
Bye!
Like, yeah, you kind of understand the one-to-one thing.
I get it, and at the same time, I'm like...
like I get under I understand why like why it exists I just
don't understand how to make it you or I don't even know how
to explain what I'm explaining sorry my brain is like so big
wait
trust the process I'm just gonna trust
open up one though.
Oh, I'm already stuck.
Maybe this was a bad thing though.
I shouldn't have played something that's so mentally taxing
on me.
Would you kindly be my friend?
I'm a maid.
I'm sorry, random person.
I don't have friends.
Thank you though.
I can be a maid.
Phil, thank you so much for the fan together.
Thank you.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna leave this area and I'm
gonna press right here.
No!
Now I just have a random two.
Minto five months.
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm sure there's many, many Aibu who would like to be
your friend.
Two.
Bravely running away from the easy one-to-one.
It's easy for you, but it's not easy for me.
So it's...
I don't... wait...
You don't have to understand, this is my third time ever
playing Mind Sweeper.
I'll be right back.
we're
gonna play pinball instead
oh what does that do oh oh oh
so close no game audio
Oh.
High speed.
Sometimes it doesn't go.
Oh, there we go.
Oh.
Get
him over.
There's a score.
I'm going to cancel.
It's okay.
How do I start a new game?
Oh, F2.
I wonder what my highest score can be.
You know, I never ever played for the score.
I just played because I enjoyed the pinball.
I was like, it's fun to make ball go around.
I enjoy that aspect.
Disappeared somewhere?
I played to try and complete all the missions.
What are the missions?
So there's like...
Light up these.
There's this.
These light up.
There's so many.
Why are you guys so mean today?
What's going on?
Having the time so many people out.
What the heck?
The blinking arrows on the left.
Oh, and then there's also like this thing, right?
Missions are given to you and as you hit various targets in
the machine.
Yeah, yeah.
The blue and the orange lights in the center light up as
they're completed.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, okay.
Let's keep going.
I want to do like missions.
Sorry that I switched from Mind Sweeper.
I just don't have the mental capacity to be called stupid
today.
I'm sorry.
So, you know.
We just, that's why I move on.
I haven't completed any more.
No!
We keep going.
So fast.
Oh yeah.
Oh, we made it!
Oh my god.
The lag is kind of crazy.
Oh no.
Hey!
What am I hitting?
Wait!
I
don't know.
Just slow.
We made it up in here.
I didn't get a single one.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll get it all.
Because I'm the last one.
Hang on.
Oh, oh, no!
No, it came over.
Good try.
I mean, more balls.
I think the flashing pale blue arrow tells you what to do
for the missions.
Flashing?
Okay, I'll look for it.
Oh my god.
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it, I see it.
So it's like, press those buttons.
Fataba!
The original backseater.
Okay, I got one.
I don't have one.
Oh my god.
That was scary.
up they
even know this had missions i just hit the ball i know me
too now i kind of i gotta like get the i gotta know how to
position the ball like oh we did all three now they're green
now they're green to hit where to hit position it to hit the
wall oh i got one Wait, wait, wait.
That should have been a hit.
I'm just...
Yeah, we got two?
Or one?
Ah!
It took me like five years to learn that the left ramp is
your base and that you need to go there for all time.
Confirm things.
I'm learning so much about this game that I decided to play
on it.
Yeah, it says stuff about, like, oh, we got a mission
accepted.
But there's, like, stuff about the ship being refueled, and
I'm like, what is happening, you know?
Oh, oh, come on.
I'm over already.
Phoebe!
Thank you so much for the read, though, right?
Thank you for the read.
Hello, Phoebe, hi.
Hi!
I saw you were singing.
I'm no longer playing...
um mind sweeper i am now playing uh i am now playing space
pinball because i feel like it
you give me flashbacks to sitting in the dark playing this
as a kid
what how are you supposed to hit that what are you supposed
to do
We beat my...
We beat it, duh.
Oh, oh, two, two.
Oh, now I need to ramp.
Now it's saying I need to ramp.
Oh, shoot.
So close.
Yeah, first try.
First try, we did it.
It's so easy.
Easiest game ever.
Now we're playing the only game like real gamers play.
Space pinball.
Oh, and this is what I needed to do before.
Oh, now the green.
Chicken invaders, what the heck is that?
Thank you guys for the gifted, by the way, thank you so
much!
Reflex shot, Lord.
Let's go.
Oh.
Mind Sweeper got abducted by aliens and we're on a space
mission to save it.
Natsukasi!
Yeah!
Hoi!
Oh!
Each of those three dots is a different mission.
Yeah!
I'm getting...
I'm understanding.
But I...
Also, it's a matter of...
hitting them.
It's kind of difficult.
Hoi!
Oh, wait!
Each of them is a different...
We wormhole again.
We wormhole it again?
I have so many distinct memories of like just...
No!
Of it like looping like that.
If you get all three at once, it's a special mission when
you go up the ramp.
I feel like I should be putting in my score.
This is my worst score yet though, so I don't want to put
that in.
Like some of the most anticipated games of the year.
Other people are playing Resident Evil 9.
And me?
I'm playing Space Cadet Pinball.
You're not the same.
People need it.
People don't know how good Space Cadet...
Oh, I got one.
Space Cadet Pinball is what...
Oh, dang it.
Oh!
I gotta launch the ramp!
To accept the mission!
No!
We gotta launch the ramp.
I gotta remember the positioning it needs to go.
I'm so close to loop.
And Ibu chooses.
Aminto obeys.
I've been thinking so much about that Bioshock, like, twist.
And just how like...
Basically, it's a damned if you do, damned if you don't
situation.
Like, they force you basically.
They're like...
It's sort of like a thing where it's like...
You have to not play the game.
To...
You know, choose.
And then just the would-you-kindly...
What do you mean?
So nice to me!
Oh gosh, I don't have the reflexes for this today.
Oh!
I need the ramp!
So it's about having no choice, yeah.
Solitaire next, now solitaire.
I can do a solitaire.
I play solitaire, draw three.
I can play the heckie out of some solitaire.
Mission accepted.
Wow, okay.
Wait, wait, wait!
Mean to.
Dang, I accepted the mission finally.
There really is lore in this game.
My dad used to play Hella Solitaire.
So basically, there would be some times when, uh, um, I
would visit, like, my grandparents.
out but um you know they had literally nothing to do my
entertainment was making my grandpa coffee and uh
and uh um so but he had a deck of cards so i would manually
put out like i would do manual solitaire would you kindly
take care of you oh take care of my trip thank you I loved
Solidarity.
Oh, we gotta go up the ramp to accept the mission.
Oh, come on.
Hoi!
Bioshock's twist is one of the best.
It's inspired by the twist in System Shock, too.
Which was...
Yeah, yeah, I do know that they did that too.
this ball hates me i know the new pokemon i like the lizard
get qua i know they're gonna make that dog ugly they're
gonna they're gonna hug that dog oh wow this one's terrible
we're not we're gonna i don't know it's okay um
is so cute
solitaire was also a big activity at my grandma's house that
are playing myself at war it's so funny
I want the grass bird I like that his name is basically
eyebrows what was it like owl brow or something oh wormhole
That was such like a clean head.
Black hole.
Brow- Oh, yeah, it's like Browt, Sprout.
I think I'm thinking of...
I was thinking...
Oh!
Dang it, I didn't have a mission to accept.
But, um...
I think in Japanese, his name is like...
Uh...
a reference to an owl and then in English it's like a sprout
with eyebrows I gotta I gotta get up there I gotta accept
the mission okay well how far down do I do I keep do I do I
um let the go to...
Like three-fourths.
Three-fourths down?
Ah, so close!
So close.
Seventh-elevenths.
Jurassic Park pinball with the T-Rex that eats your balls.
I've never seen that before.
Except the mission.
Oh!
Okay, we gotta go up the ramp.
All right, we'll let it.
Hoi!
Noo!
Surprise, there isn't more pinball.
Pinball is so fun.
It's also very like...
Thank you!
Please don't spam, though.
Please don't spam.
It's also very like...
What's the word?
You can focus on it, but it can also be very mind...
Head empty, sort of.
Turn your brain off activity if you just want to launch
ball.
Oh,
we saved it.
Oh, man.
Me too.
There's a Senron Kagura pinball game.
do they like bounce off of the the you know how many hours
I've seen pinball should have been doing homework it's like
a it's like a rite of passage as a child pinball is just not
popular anymore we just to bring it back.
Okay, we accepted the mission.
Ugh.
Take me back in there.
Oh, you...
The other one.
It's like an IRL pinball.
If you're...
If you have to pay for it like at a bar or something then it
sucks you know but if you were just playing if you're like
you i don't know i guess pinball machines aren't super
expensive anymore correct me if i'm wrong
oh we're accepting the mission
oh my god okay i see the arrow at the very top Oh,
I love that sound.
They can be more expensive.
Really?
The MGS patchy slot?
Unlucky.
Yeah, pretty unlucky there.
No, we lost our mission.
Who is so?
Oh, like crazy about, oh my gosh, you probably know every,
like, if the ball was at this angle.
Sorry, coming in with that was much louder than I thought it
would be.
Coming in at this angle, then you're gonna do this and hit
it as fast.
Oh, thank you for all the suggestions.
Oh, I gotta...
I'm not focused at all.
They're definitely pinball perverts.
It's a good name for them.
Pinball perverts.
Makes me want to find my old 3D ultra pinball CDs.
Especially creep night.
Creep.
I'll name this one after you.
I'm a creep.
I'm a weird.
I think I like pinball.
I might be a pinball pervert.
I'm a creep.
I'm a weird...
I think I'm just a pervert.
I might just be a normal pervert.
Oh, so close, so close.
Hello?
Sometimes it's annoying.
Oh, look at this.
Rare art and game mechanics that makes them valuable.
Some towns and cities have old machines and museums.
I think that the ball should always be able to get hit by
the level.
We accepted the mission!
What's our mission?
Okay, we gotta go to the guy all the way up there.
Please, hit the one.
Please, there's just another one.
No.
Wait.
Ah!
No, my vision.
Short, weird...
Cute, short, and weird ghost sure plays on me and pinball.
I don't know.
I haven't even hit, like, One million.
Fish and mailed.
Oh.
Hit the wall.
Not that wall.
So if I already have those lit up, I wonder if it needs to
be lit up again.
Who's in here?
Ew, something was moving behind me.
Sorry, I got distracted.
I thought I had a cat in my room.
And something was moving behind me.
Wait, hold on.
There is already a ghost in here.
If you're trying to haunt here, it's taken.
I'm not accepting any more roommates.
Sorry, I've lost that one.
Because usually if my cats are in here, I want to like, you
know, Let them, let them leave.
Because they start meowing at me.
Re-I will pinball.
No, hit the wall.
Wait, hold on.
I'll re-pressure the cat.
Two seconds.
I also tried to pause by hitting escape and it didn't let
me.
Just letting you know, there was an attempt to pause the
game.
Dang it.
Ship roof, refuel the door.
The flippers are my hands.
I love that idea.
Alright.
Oh!
I did it!
Nice.
Pause is clear.
Oh no!
Can I restart my mission?
It did.
Dang it.
Oh, so close.
Should be refueled.
Does the ball run out of fuel or something?
What are we doing?
Wait.
That's great.
I love that.
The noises in this game are too iconic.
This
game Gallagher and bejeweled twists.
Oh yeah.
It's so awesome.
No!
Oh!
So unlucky.
Wait!
Why soon?
We gotta get it in the hole up there, which is...
I need to get back up there is kind of a pain.
My highest score!
3D Ibu Pinball where we are the balls and the flippers are
your hands.
That'd be so fun.
mint million I'm just vibing I'm not gonna lie I'm just here
you know I'm you know I knew that my days would be busy this
week I did not estimate that I would have so little mental
capacity so I apologize oh
What does the green thing do?
Wait!
Some credits for the machine.
Oh, thank you!
Okay, so now we have to hit the wall.
I don't remember what the...
No.
I didn't reach out at the same time.
Well, that's why I'm not getting very far, maybe.
Come on, hit the...
Hit the wall!
Huy!
It's really me just kind of glancing at chat, anyway.
Field multiplier times two!
Two!
Yes!
Okay, now we gotta...
I wonder if I can do this.
do it here no apologies needed shinsu later thank you so
much for the time got it thank you all right
oh so close
that was so bad
That was so bad!
Okay, we got our mission.
Hoi!
Nope.
It did not come at the correct angle and the right velocity.
The ball must be...
Must be going at...
The mega speed.
Oh, nice.
Weapons upgraded.
They're my weapons?
Is that what they are?
Oh!
No!
So close, so close, so close.
My flags have been upgraded.
I'm getting everything but the mission.
There was a defense.
Okay, all right, here we go, here we go.
Oh!
Second chance I keep going too far down I guess Third chance
Virtuous space mission I love your nerd voice Okay Yes we
need the frame perfect setup to proceed at the optimal angle
Angel That could be your angle or your angel I feel like
Mint would enjoy Insan Aquarium I have played.
I've streamed in Santa Aquarium before.
Mind Sweeper looking a lot different.
Yup.
No!
I keep doing it.
She can't stop.
I need to just accept the mission.
Yes!
The mission has been.
been accepted!
Brrrrrrrrr!
Hit that one guy!
Hit the guy!
Oh my god, that was getting the heck out of me.
Oh wait!
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's a little stressful.
When I'm trying, when I have an objective, I thought I was
just...
Flip ball!
We're in hyperspace!
Oh my god, I'm just...
hitting everything, but the one little bump that I need to.
Also, we need to do high score.
Maybe now.
Oh!
Oh my god.
The one time I don't want to go up the ramp.
No!
I was so close.
number one baby hey no high score though yeah new PB new PB
good job team
good job team good job team
pinball master thank you
okay this is run i'm getting more comfortable out of it as
you can tell my score is going up we're going up oh we're
going we're gonna be gonna be
nice how do i okay this is to oh oh i didn't even do it wait
penalty for that.
Okay, this is not the run, then.
No way!
Well, I wouldn't have to tilt if the dang spring worked.
I only wanted to see what button was the tilt.
I didn't draw.
I didn't know.
It's okay.
This is not the run, anyway.
I'll just let it die.
Get him lower.
here we go all right this this is the right okay all right
go three two one ground control to major time oh the
engine's on and may god love me with you
This is a magic town, the ground control.
It's the peculiar way Need to sing more Bowie I don't know
very much David Bowie, I'll be honest
Ground control, come major time There's something wrong, can
you hear me?
Can you hear me?
Minto time Can you hear me?
Nothing in my team Can Far above the world Let the earth Let
the earth escape And there's nothing I can do Oh
Papapapapapapapapap A bubble down Go down, down
What do you need me in here to do?
I think it changes the position of the light.
What?
Oh, it does!
Oh, my God, I see it.
That's crazy.
That's huge news.
Thank you.
So we can get all three.
That's huge news.
Thank you for the very delicious piece of information.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't mean to tilt.
I pressed the wrong button.
500,000 exactly.
Well, Black Star is good too, you know, damn boy.
Maybe I'll sing about next karaoke.
I wanted to do karaoke next week.
Because I've been, like, recording a bunch of stuff.
I kind of want to just sing whatever I want to, you know?
But maybe I should rest my voice at the same time.
We're hitting every light.
Alright, let's try this again.
Up the ramp.
Upies!
Oh, nice!
Got all three!
I don't even have to flip.
Wait!
Fuck!
I was bawling too hard.
Not my PB.
PB and J.
I didn't have dinner because I didn't really have time to go
possess anybody, find anyone to possess, or find any
offerings.
And...
That was craziness.
and uh so now i'm kind of hungry don't take my pizza that
sounds like an invitation
when i grab a snack well that's the thing because i'm
leaving i don't really have so much so
I would have to go out and get something, you know?
Oh, dang it.
That was pretty close, though.
It was not at the optimal angle for then.
We can entertain ourselves if we want to grab something.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
I feel like...
know we'll be not be able to stream so much i want to be
able to just hang out you know
i'll go cook something as an offering no don't cook for an
offering this is an offering is like something you know
you're like you have a snack or something it's okay though
guys really i'll eat after stream oh oh yes oh i did the
flip i did the flip i did it i did it i did it i took the
the information that was given to me and i applied it and i
That was so lame!
So lame!
Straight in the middle.
I know!
There's always cannibalism.
It's been zero days since cannibalism was last mentioned on
Amito's screen.
Picked up other childhood games.
Chips Challenge.
I don't know that.
I think I've discovered the angle.
I think I've discovered the angle at which I need to, um...
Oh, I had it.
Oh!
Mission has been accepted.
Please.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Okay, we need to go back onto the ramp.
You guys!
Did my score!
My score!
You did the mission!
Oh my god!
We did it!
Oh no!
Straight down the middle.
One mil!
Almost at two million!
One mil, baby!
Holy cow!
Missions are worthless, go!
What did the mission?
You are learning fast!
Thank you!
I don't think I did anything, though.
At least for that.
You know?
Kinda was just like, oh, luck there.
Maybe.
Oh.
Ah!
This girl just scored yeah we were at the mercy of the ball
in pinball
chips challenge what is that what kind of game is that
i wish we can borrow we're real oh nice
I have to go in the ramp again.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, wait, no!
It's a
pine sweeper pinball free cell.
Them is hard, solitaire, spider solitaire.
Wait, I kind of want to play Solitaire now.
I wonder if there's, like, any good...
I'll change the title of the stream to be, like...
Windows Classics, you know, but...
I wonder if there's a good way to play Solitaire.
I wonder if there's something.
It's, like, one of the few games I have on my phone.
You got games on your phone?
Yeah, baby, I got Solitaire.
I've got games on my phone.
Nice.
I did the flip.
No!
Solitaire and Blue Archive and Meow Tower.
Let's see.
I have...
Meow Tower, Blue Archive.
Solitaire.
blackjack oh my god i forgot i had this too um it's like one
of those one of those ad games though it's one of the ones
that the color sort games where like you have the pipes and
you have to sort the colors but i forgot that
yeah i got blackjack yeah baby As a kid, I wondered why
there was a goat head on the top left of this board.
For the first time, I just realized it's a spaceship, not a
goat.
This?
I'm attempting to see your vision?
Thanks for my daily meow tower reminder, of course.
You see a goat?
Wait, like...
are the ears.
Usually I have like, I usually feel like I can see these
kinds of things, but I can't.
Oh, maybe a little bit.
Like the the, this part at the tip is like the nose, right?
Complete my missions.
I think I see it.
The ghost is hella deformed.
I think you as a kid needed glasses.
The only goat I see is in the bottom right.
Yeah, maybe more of a wolf.
This is a goat she's streaming right now.
Oh my gosh, I should have taught Ayami that.
She asked me today.
with some things you know she asked me today she's like
what's a what's a popular meme the kids are saying in
english i feel like goat is always relative you know but
instead i said a boo-boo matcha latte or what do my
chocolate whatever it's called dang it i missed it
i wasn't gonna teach her six seven i think she might
actually like say it all the time Nice.
She probably knows a Roku Nano, no?
That's what the kids are saying in Japan, no.
Maybe.
Give her brain a lot.
Oh, that was close.
No, no, no, no.
She's on my mission, no!
Brain rot is worldwide.
It's funny, like the...
Spread my code.
I mean, got my globe?
What does that mean?
Oh, you got the globe!
What is it?
There's like a certain...
One of those like brain rot memes.
It's a girl with like a teapot on her head.
And it's actually kind of popular in Japan.
And you'll see like...
You'll see like two cosplayer girls.
Cosplaying it and stuff.
Meow.
Meow, meow, meow.
It's like a...
Oh, shit.
Dang it.
I was...
I was wrong.
Oh, I got it.
Neat.
It's like just a girl with a...
It's like a pot on her head.
It's part of the Italian brain...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Italian brain rot memes.
Oh, that was dark.
won't stop singing rest in peace my granny she got hit by a
bazooka from tick tock tick tock is so strange because it's
it feels it's sort of like any sort of social media platform
how like you can be on your your feed can be flooded with so
much stuff and you can be on you could never see another
side of the whole site the final line in the zet's op is be
the goat i'm so behind on Zets.
I can't even watch it on the plane.
I'm so sad.
I have other stuff I need.
I have work that I have to do on the plane.
So late.
Nice.
Oh!
I will watch some movies, though.
Let's see what I can do.
Released.
It's my only time that I get to watch the new movies.
Like I got to watch weapons.
Oh, recently.
Did you guys see the new backrooms movie that's coming out?
Yeah, the Precure is detective theme.
It's so cute.
Do not watch FNAF 2.
Why not?
Zets has been super good.
I loved what I watched of it.
It looks potentially good.
That's how I, yeah, I would say that too.
I would say it looks potentially good.
I don't know, though.
100 meters.
What's that?
Well, I can only watch things that are on the plane, so...
I haven't seen Iron Monk yet.
Wait.
On
the plane, though.
Oh, come on.
What?
Crash bonus?
So I'm guessing it redeploys if it...
falls through and you don't touch it and then you get the it
crashes if you do touch the the flippers
right marty supreme give it a watch i've never heard of it
before every
time i fly now i look for the top gun maverick movie because
of you top gun maverick is so good to watch on a plane
especially when you get turbulence because you're not scared
of the turbulence you're like whoa this is so immersive and
then you can just i i feel like i've watched it enough at
this point i i
redeploy while one of the red lights on the bottom is on oh
okay okay but i've watched it so many times at this point i
don't care about the subplot with tom cruz with I know
exactly what parts to click to skip those so that I can get
back to the mission.
A backroom's movie is made by the guy who did the original
YouTube web series.
Oh, what?
That's crazy.
I did not know that.
What about
the movie I watched recently?
Okay, so there's some background lore to why I watched this
movie.
I heard that this movie had a crazy plot.
We're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna talk for a minute
before I go back to Space Cadet.
I was like, okay.
And it's by this lady.
It's, so they've been like, there's been like a bunch of
adaptations of her books recently.
Um, hold on.
Colleen Hoover.
Now I've never read any of her books.
Yes.
Oh my gosh, you knew before I even said it.
Colleen Hoover.
I've never read any of her books.
They're like, like they're like sexy adult books which you
would think that i would have read them but i haven't um and
they're all kind of like
questionable in terms of the story of these novels never
heard of her you know what that's great there was a there
was a movie that came out of one of her books recently i
can't even remember It's called, hold on, it's called, uh,
Colleen Hoover movie, hold on, uh, regretting you, okay, and
I heard that the plot for this was kind of crazy, so I was
like, okay, now I kind of want to watch the movie, but I
want to watch it without giving a dime, you know what I
mean?
and there's a guy and the girl her sister has a boyfriend
wait hold on there's the guy is dating the girl's sister and
the girl has her own boyfriend okay um so there's there's a
girl and a guy girl's sister has a boyfriend and girl is
dating a guy.
So there's, you know, everybody's taken.
But apparently the girl and the guy like each other, but
they never get together.
And then they all like grow up and get married to like, so
the girl gets married to the guy she was dating and then the
sister gets married to the other guy.
Okay.
Actually, maybe, let me draw this.
actually hold on okay imagine the flippers girl guy and oh
my god I can use my mouse that's so cute we need a diagram
this isn't working hold on okay actually no this works this
works this is the boyfriend turned husband and the sister.
So the boyfriend turned husband and the girl, they have a
kid.
And then the sister and the guy, they have a kid.
And then the kid, wait, hold on.
Were they related?
Wait, no, I think so.
But anyway, it turns out that the husband and the sister
were cheating.
They were getting together.
Because they liked each other.
But then these two, these two flippers liked each other.
And then they die.
So this plane or this spaceship, that's why this is them.
They die.
And they find out that they were cheating because they died.
The sister and the husband die.
And so then the girl and the guy that originally liked each
other, they were like, well, we always liked each other.
Yeah, I know I always liked you.
And I'm sad that my wife and your sister cheated, but I
always liked you more.
I always liked you too.
there was the daughter of the husband that died and the girl
and the daughter likes a guy i don't know why she is related
or why she has anything to do but the guy that she likes
he's like some kind of you know he's he's a kid with no
aspirations and he has to stay in the small town and take
care of his grandpa because his grandpa is dying and he's
got no money to do anything.
He's been living in poverty his whole life.
Except it turns out that the grandpa was like, actually,
son.
He says this at the end of the movie.
He's like, actually, son, I know you've been living in
poverty this entire, you know, you're almost graduated from
high school.
You've been living in poverty for your entire life.
But actually, I have a secret fortune.
and then everybody gets together and it's a happy ending
except the two that died
sounds like two different movies is there an epic car chase
or something no it was such a so when i first heard this
plot i knew i had heard that like someone was cheating on
somebody and then somebody died but then i also heard that
like the the daughter started to like the boy and then that
that maybe they were related and i was like this is this is
too wackadoo this is too crazy i need to watch this movie
because how is this like a mainstream media sort of
like what in the yosugano Sora is happening so um but they
weren't related which is i guess a good thing this is the
plot of kuzuno honkai but worse because it's not anime What
an interesting story.
You thought you were dirt poor your whole life?
Well, it was just a prank.
Yeah, he was just like, the grandpa was like, I always told
you about my fortune.
And it's real.
And the guy was like, I thought you were just kidding.
Kuzi no Hongkai.
I don't know that actually.
Wait, I'm looking it up.
Maybe I recognize it if I saw it.
Oh!
I do recognize this.
That's crazy.
If you want to watch a crazy story kind of similar, but not
really.
Uh, Kimi Nozo.
Kimi Nozo.
That is like,
original like damn we need to kill this guy type anime
like when I think of damn we need to kill this guy type
anime I think of that I think of oh no I think of school
days which he does so it's all good it actually that comes
true.
Nice bolt.
Not, not, nice bolt.
No, not, nice bolt.
Okay, we did not lock in for that one.
Sorry, I was too busy telling my Colleen Hoover.
Now I want to, like, watch more Colleen Hoover movies
because it didn't even ask me for my high score, my name.
It was, like, score too low.
Bozo.
The dude from school days made me irrationally angry.
He made me hate Makoto's forever, maybe.
He's the guy.
He's not kind of.
He's like the actual worst.
He's so terrible.
So what goes nice, but...
Not nice, but...
No, not nice, but...
Harper Spear!
Simple hug!
Oh, dang.
Oh, jackpot doubled!
Oh, he accepted the mission.
I gotta do the mission.
So we can get to the mission.
May I introduce you to his father?
Whose father?
What are we talking about?
Oh no, I just realized I need the...
I don't need the...
I thought I needed the bumper up there.
No, I need the light.
Dang it.
The light!
I need the light!
No!
Oh!
Meme, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Dang it.
I feel like we did so much, but my...
My jackpot was doubled, yet...
Have I ever seen the family tree?
Wait, no, I haven't.
Holy cow.
Now I want to.
It's been so long since I've...
Oh, okay.
Since I've played...
School days, or watched it for that matter.
Warning,
low fuel!
Oh my god, my balls actually do drain.
Two million!
Yeah!
Yeah, baby!
Ship refueled!
We are safe.
Hoi!
Bonus.
Okay.
Hoi!
No!
Yuck!
Pinball wizard!
We are so good, baby.
Are you winning?
I think so, actually.
I think I might actually be winning, guys.
That
was so sad.
That was so sad.
Meantle.
Number one.
Two mil.
Two mil, baby.
She did it.
She won't.
mind the timing.
How did I do that?
Curse by the god of comedic timing.
Blah.
Curse you.
Boom, intelligent.
Should we play Solitaire?
Hold on.
I'll look it up.
I don't want to like get the, you know how like Windows is
like, you know, can I play it here?
Solitaire.
Yeah, it's a Windows XP stream, yeah.
Uh.
Oh, maybe here.
Play.
Don't get a virus.
I don't get a virus.
Classic?
Hold on.
Let me see how it looks.
I might have to download it.
All these don't look right, you know what I mean?
hmm don't be suspicious don't be suspicious don't be
suspicious and don't be suspicious and don't be suspicious
and don't be suspicious you know i'll just do this one it
should be fine one second they don't look like you know the
one that i'm used to that's the thing i was trying to find
like the older one you know okay hold on
I gotta scooch it over.
Not me.
The game.
And we'll put my music back on.
Is this draw three?
This is easy.
No, stop telling me what to do.
Let me look at the menu and stuff.
Game options.
draw three oh okay I had to restart draw one is the only way
to play not I I don't like draw one she's
not dead go get her oh what wait is there BGM no
I mean there BGM for the for the salt hair I don't hear it I
don't hear any
I don't like the hints.
I want it to tell me to... I want it to tell it to stop.
Oh, music?
Off.
Uh, alerts.
Undo, hmm?
Oh, hints.
Oh, there's... Alert!
This is Bilatro?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Hmm.
Ooh.
I'll wait.
I've
been watching you for five months through YouTube and
catching streams lately.
Me too cute.
Sorry, I don't know your emotes for YouTube.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Minky of the Lush Retro Alley.
What do the cards say?
Draw.
That's kind of tough.
I'm not being true.
Maybe.
Where should I see?
Draw three is the only way.
Agreed.
I have like so many six.
Oh.
Nice.
The worst thing when you do move a car.
and it's the same card underneath.
I need Red 7.
Ask and you shall receive.
That was crazy!
I need...
No!
It's under there!
Five parts?
Oh, thank you.
Stop!
Why would you tell me that?
Oh, you're right.
I forgot that I can put things up.
Wait.
Still think I'm... still think I'm not in a good spot,
though.
Under where?
I still, I think we're still, we're still not good.
You like the art in my thumbnail, me so cute?
Thank you, it was drawn by my mama.
Thank you so much for the 20 again.
The card I need is under there.
I mean it's under, it's, it's, uh, the card, the card is,
uh,
Yeah, you guys say underwear!
Okay, new game.
What the?
What is a grand master?
What's the difference?
It's solitaire.
How is it more difficult?
What?
What does that mean?
Is it shuffled more poorly?
Or something?
How does it get more difficult?
Okay.
A whole lot of nothing.
She will learn.
Will I regret my words and my deeds?
This is more a game that I can Zatsu to, which is kind of as
one of the kings stabs you.
It would be more interesting if there was a count down than
a count up, you know?
If it was just like, you have to get it within this time
where the king stabs you.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, actually, let's do this.
Yeah, baby.
I don't know if even that's proper.
If you put something up here, are you allowed to take it
down?
Oh, I should have done it for this.
Oh, well.
I've kept up draw each day up for 54 days.
In 3.85 years, I'll be good enough to design bunny mint.
Want the hoodie over it?
Laced up front?
Frills?
Why in so many years?
Maybe it's strats to the order you pulled.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I assume this randomizer and grammar.
Master gives you worse hands.
I guess so?
I guess so, maybe?
This seems like pretty what I'm used to playing, so I don't
I don't see quite the difference.
Each ear takes a one year.
Oh, I see.
If I had a king, I put him right there and here.
This is where I put my king.
If I had one.
Oh, it tells you if you have no more moves.
Wait, did I...
Did I mess up before?
Maybe...
Wait, is this the same game?
Is this the same game?
Why would you give me the same game?
Yeah, not all solitaire's are winnable.
Exactly.
Why would they give me the same one?
We'll do random.
That's the easiest, probably.
The most fair.
I hit retry, but I thought it would shuffle the deck.
That's so stupid.
Like that's so dumb.
I don't know what to do here yet, so.
I don't really get sweaty about the games that I play.
You know what I mean?
Some people will like be like, no, you have to do this and
then do this and this and this and this in this order and it
will allow you.
But to me, I just, I don't know.
Oh, I just noticed this one.
I just vibe more than anything, I think.
Oh!
You get it.
So when people, like, you know, if I want a challenge, then
I'll, you know, this is, doing draw three is more of a
challenge than not.
The min-maxers.
They scare me.
I know we'll win one though, for sure.
Ah, okay.
I had a feeling.
I'll do this.
It might be a mistake, but...
XP!
What is a Vegas mode?
I've never heard of that before.
What's a Vegas mode, Solitaire?
Is it like you get a certain number of moves or something?
The only time I've imposed challenges on myself is, for
games I've played way too much.
Like, I have 12 plus runs of Elden Ring under my belt.
Holy.
Hard games at grandma's house are not meant to be needlessly
overcomplicated.
Vegas mode is where it keeps track of theoretical money
you've spent.
Takes your money.
Oh!
So if I draw, it takes money?
Is that what you're telling me?
I don't even know you could gamble, Solitaire.
Wait.
We'll save that in case there's another king.
What did I say?
I don't know though, this is looking pretty bleak.
Unless I get like a...
Unless I get a...
Red 8, we're stuck.
Yippee!
It's
tough Well Hmm Hmm
Oh yeah yeah yeah Oh guys?
Guys?
I think this is the run
So What's happening?
Whoa!
What's going on?
That was crazy.
That was so funny.
I kind of want to play, I want to try Vegas mode.
The blackjacks that I play, they're like Vegas mode.
So, um, I bet money.
Not real money.
No, I don't, I don't gamble.
YouTube, I do not know, no, gam, no, none.
It's not, it's not happening.
What did you put in that solitaire deck?
But it's like a fake.
It's fake.
It's all in game.
I haven't spent a real dollar at all.
This hand sucks.
You.
Have I ever played Blackjack with my life on the line?
What do you mean plays B?A.
I told you about Blackjack, not Blue Archive.
Stupids.
I said I never gave money to the Blackjack overlords.
The Blue Archive overlords now?
I have.
YouTube, she doesn't gamble.
She just plays gotcha Vegas style.
I have given money.
Okay, this one sucks.
No game.
Wait, it hasn't told me that I have no moves left, though.
What do I have?
What am I missing?
What did my eyes not see?
Money for Koharu.
Koharu right now is at relationship level 49.
And I didn't have to spend any money to get her to 50.
Oh, there it is.
Out of 100?
Yeah.
But if you don't play Blue Archive,
you don't realize how much of a feat that is without
spending money.
It is a feat in of itself.
Maybe I should have done that.
A feat.
It is a feat.
It's a foot.
Feet.
VTuber feet?
Fortunately reruns don't seem to be too long in between.
The spark system can kiss my butt though.
Blue archive?
Yeah, I agree.
Sure.
Okay, greedy.
Stole it out of his hands.
This is not a very good hand, either.
You're my first Super Chat founder, Portal VOD last fall,
and I've been enjoying your streams ever since.
Portal 2 is my favorite game ever.
Thank you in advance for those recordings and safe travels.
Enrichment TV!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I'm excited for you guys to watch them.
I feel like I did some real big brain...
Well, I get stupid, but I did some real big brain activity
in them, too.
And I feel like the thumbnail art is so cute.
I have to pee.
I
have this song stuck in my head.
What's that song?
Tell me.
You know that song.
It drops of Jupiter.
I have it stuck in my...
head because because I saw I saw TikTok of of of uh of
Trane, the lead singer of Trane singing it and he's like he
was just singing it he's like singing it at the Golden Gate
Bridge and he's just like tell me and the comments are so
funny the The first comment is...
They're so mean.
The first comment is CEO of one song.
That's so mean.
This is...
It's so mean.
Ugh.
Didn't Train also do like, Hey, soul, sister.
I feel like that was their popular song, no?
Being a one-hit wonder.
I feel like it's a curse and a blessing.
Because, you know, like, it's a curse and that.
It's like if you want to maintain relevance and status and
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Like, obviously it's tougher to do that.
same time there's so much less pressure maybe i feel like
one hit wonders don't really exist anymore you think so
maybe because it's because so many people like don't listen
to the radio anymore i don't know
yeah most people don't even get one yeah tell me it's
because of spotify Huh, maybe.
Stuck in my head.
But it's just because I saw that comment.
Neuron.
CEO of One Song.
Kids are cool, Jack.
That is savage, no?
I wonder if there's, like, lore behind.
behind that.
Maybe he'd like, maybe the band posts like a bunch of
videos, but it's him singing that one song.
You know what I mean?
Just like the good old days.
Put that down there.
I might regret it later, but right now we won't.
Drops of Jupiter next karaoke and my life is yours.
I think I could I don't think, I don't know if I remember
it, so, uh, I could try.
Whoa!
Thank you so much!
Oh!
Hey, Minto, Mindy, Mick Minterson.
I'm about to propose to my beloved, and I'm so excited.
I can't stand it.
We haven't talked about marriage yet, and I know...
Wait, you know that's risky.
Could you wish me luck, and also what's your ring?
size i am so mad i got some like custom rings i was like
i've been in my like i've been in my era of like i want
jewelry but i've only been buying jewelry from like like
places that are like kind of not homemade like like they are
like they're small businesses you know what i mean i'm in my
like my my era of like it it feels like like there was one
place I wanted to buy from and she like makes the little
like glass glass animals on the necklaces and stuff it's not
Etsy but yeah kind of I'm like in my indie era exactly and I
got these rings and they're so cute and I measured I was
like, I'm gonna...
Glasgow.
I was like, I'm gonna get this right.
Because I've never measured my ring size before.
And then I sent it out.
And then maybe, I guess, when I measured it, I was like,
damn, I have fat fingers, man.
I have such fat fingers.
And I...
I...
I looked up the average, like, finger size.
And it was, my finger size was bigger.
I was like, no way.
chonkers i have damn sausages and then i get my rings coming
and they were too big
so i have to take them to a jeweler's to get them small
so i don't know my ring size because i apparently can't
measure it myself ah i have them literally right here
masterful deflection What do you mean?
I'm telling you about my ring size.
There's such pretty rings though.
My hands are tiny.
No, I have chunky fingers.
Where she can see them?
Wrong.
She can't ignore you and talk about her fat fingers.
FOOT!
FOOT?
What?
FOOB!
FOOBIT!
FOOBITBOP!
Thank you so much for the Aqua Supa.
the pink thank you thank you thank you good luck with good
luck with your beloved
you know you're supposed to measure the same finger every
time i did i did i'm scared to wear them out because they're
custom you know
maybe i can wear them on my thumb
It's so big.
And I'm too scared because they are custom to take them to
a...
I'm like, I've been trying to research jewelry stores in my
area.
Because I was like, what if I take it to a bad one?
I don't want to drop another ring in the toilet.
Literally, Murphy!
That's exactly what I thought.
Oh my god.
I was with Matara and we went to a restaurant.
I can say this now.
Wait.
I went to the restaurant to meet with someone from V.
Shoujo JP.
She was like, Mitara was like, yeah, you could talk to them
and see how V.
Shoujo would be.
And then my ring, I was in the bathroom.
My ring flew off my finger straight into the toilet.
That was a sign.
Oh my god!
It was an omen.
oh god
that was forever ago yeah but i don't want it to happen
again to my custom made rings
just like golem dropped the one ring luckily the ring i
dropped though i think it was like 500 yen girl you actually
have ghost powers well i'm a ghost i don't think i have any
powers though what an omen oh my god i just thought of that
now that's crazy did you have to flush it yeah i did i
didn't reach my hand actually i think it was after i had
already flushed if i remember correctly so somebody walked
in there and saw my ring
someone probably went in there i was like
you just left it what else am i supposed to do it's a ring
it's not like a poop or anything it's just a rig I'm
not gonna stick my hand in the toilet of oh my god we've
been on this one for seven minutes I'm not gonna stick my
hand in the toilet of a public toilet that's terrible that's
a that's the worst thing you could do.
James Sunderland would do it.
I'll only do it then if I'm James Sunderland.
Depends on the ring's worth.
I said it was like 500 yen.
It was very cheap.
Oh, I just noticed.
I was like, wait a second.
No!
Unlucky.
Unless unless...
black six unlucky youtuber why no mind sweeper because i
didn't understand something and people were like oh it's not
that hard and that just hurts my feeling so i switched to
something that wouldn't you know hurt my feelings sorry one
day when i when i feel a little more it kind of it did put a
little bit about a bad taste in my mouth so one day when i
feel no bad more feelings about about oh i didn't mean that
i thought it was a about mind sweeper then i'll return to it
but you know some people get things very easily and some
people don't and it's mean to say like it's not that hard
when everybody's comprehension is different that's all i
gotta say about that
one time i lost my workplace's badge in the clutches of a
toilet it went with a It was pretty funny.
The explanation to HR was not.
I think the explanation to HR would be pretty funny.
All you have to say is...
And then it went...
Yeah.
One year of Mito.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Mind Sweeper is hard.
I think you were doing great.
Thank you.
It's one thing when I am trying to learn something off
stream.
But it's another thing when...
Um...
I'm, you know, I'm juggling chat, I'm juggling the game, I'm
juggling so many messages trying to explain things, but...
I don't understand.
There's a lot of stuff, so...
That's, that's it, though.
I have three...
I've lost three pairs of blue light glasses to toilets.
I can't even ex- I thought...
That's... Your glasses?
streamer brain is a real thing it is uh if you're going down
the nostalgia rabbit hole for old childhood flash games i
would suggest ruffle extension and using way back machine
for cartoon network pbs nicolodean disney channel i only
played some of the cartoon network games i didn't play
anything else would that be so fun thank you so much for the
akasuma thank you thank you thank
maybe I could try some old old flash games that like I never
played before but then I feel I mean I guess you if you
played it you might under you might feel the nostalgia but I
wonder if if it's like if I don't feel the nostalgia it's
just kind of like a oh this seems cool you know next week we
could like could just add it to the list of things that I
that I have that I could play while I'm away
people don't people don't often realize streamers especially
YouTubers are micromanaging 57 different 57.83 different
things behind the scenes sometimes you know like yeah yes
and no um
I don't like usually to blame that kind of stuff because
ultimately I have fun and I think that this is, it's fun and
it's easy, you know this VTubing is so easy streaming is so
easy to me but sometimes just like I said, you know it's
been a rough week for me so I would rather have my last
stream before I goal uh on my trip to be fun vibes and not
me getting sad because you know i'm getting frustrated over
not understanding something and having people you know some
people yelling at me so that's why we just pivot you should
try 3d pinball space cadet mr fox mr fox out of heaven you
are like an hour and a half too late i hit two million oh
wait oh my gosh i still have the tab
I still have the tab open.
Yeah, baby.
Pinball lives on.
I'm surprised it hasn't made any noises in the background or
anything.
Okay, time to figure out what to do.
Oh, okay.
I'll do that.
Oh, I will do that.
Noise?
Not noise.
He was waiting for you to notice in its silence.
But today we just have old PC variety games.
That's fun, too.
Thanks, guys, for being so patient with me.
During my tumultuous period.
Everything is so crazy right now.
We're rolling easy tonight.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
I guess I could do this.
Oh, oh, just kidding.
Sorry.
Oh, I thought that was louder than I expected.
Boo!
Yeah.
You.
This is the reality of playing Solitaire.
Draw three.
You lose so many games.
Or maybe it's just me.
Maybe I lose so many games.
It's all of us.
Nah, it's just how...
It is just how it goes, right?
I know I could have put that too there.
Oh, oh.
I might be able to grab that four.
Dang it, I think I needed that four.
Maybe we can get it again.
Oh, wait, this is the same game!
Oh my god.
I just realized it's the same game.
Have you heard of the upcoming game, Forbidden Solitaire?
No.
Is it sexy?
There's a game that I have wishlist.
Hold on, let me see.
Uh...
Is it this one?
Hold on, I might play the trailer.
Oh.
Whoa.
It is!
Oh, maybe it's not this.
Well, yes it is.
No.
It was like...
Oh, uh...
It's Blackjack.
Oh, what's it called?
Wait, how do I see my wish list?
Oh, wishlist.
This one, though, Menherium is what it's called.
But it's like...
It's like a...
It's not Bellatro.
Brave Junction!
Wait, is it this one?
Oh, oops.
Wait, no.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Is this the one with Blackjack?
Yeah.
Anime Girl Blackjack, but it's like an RPG too.
I haven't played it yet, though.
I haven't even gotten it yet, so.
Diablo 2 Remake got released on Steam the other week.
No way?
What do you mean, the remake?
Appreciate you streaming for us this fight.
Everything you got going on.
Pinball segment was a great nostalgia blast.
Safe travel to Mara Boss.
Thank you!
Yeah, you know, it's the least I can do.
Oh, I missed the six, but that's okay.
It is the least I could do to stream.
You know, I, my, I do like to do events and things like
that, and they do make me busy, but I still try at least to,
Keep streaming as much as I possibly can in the times that
to make up for, you know, the fact that I can then do
events.
Does that make sense?
Video from Atlantis.
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Thank you.
Hey, Mickey, I just got here.
Hope you've had a good stream.
Hope you have fun on your trip.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
How's she?
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Get that.
You're wonderful in Nimi's concert, by the way.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
That's so much fun.
I don't know if Nimi talked about some behind the scenes
stuff.
Actually, maybe I should ask her before I storytime some
things because I don't know how much she would want to keep
secret about some of the stuff.
She has a little, not sure what all you want to say though.
Yeah, I'll have to watch her stream about it.
My go-to in the Windows 3.1 days was a Mahjong Solitaire
game, Microsoft called Taipei for some reason.
It was in one of the game packs Microsoft distributed so the
OS would seem less scary to new users.
What the heck is Windows 3?
3.1.
Play some chips challenge.
It's a win 3.
What is a win 3.1?
You guys are old, I think.
Uh-oh.
Before... You guys are old, I think.
It became before Windows 95.
Oh, no.
You are old.
I think you guys are old.
I didn't even, I've never even heard of Windows 30.1.
Help, I'm turning to dust.
Out in yourselves a little bit, maybe.
Minto, please, my bones.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
No, well, I wish I wish ah
Dang Okay, hold on undo last oh hold on We're gonna we're
gonna undo a little bit We're gonna do that and see if it
saves the run now I have a choice Minto exposing us all
these
What was your first windows, Minto?
Hmm, probably like one of those that you push up, you know?
Not a sliding window or anything like that.
Probably a push-up window.
If I had to guess.
Slide to the side was my first.
That's a good choice.
No crank.
No, no.
Funny joke Funny joke Let's do this one Nope never mind
Let's do the next one
Oh Well shucks I think there's no saving this run
Nope Use code boomer for your next three game game gamer
subs tub i need my minto flavor minto flavor will be
eventually i think it's like my fault i have like i think
actually i don't remember i should check that out what's
I don't remember.
What flavor will it be?
I want it to... I...
It's like a...
It's like a melon cream soda flavor.
But what I recommend is...
If you get it.
And you try it.
Don't put so much of the powder in it.
It's better if it's like a light...
It's like a light taste.
In my opinion.
Yeah, then it tastes a little bit more melon cream soda.
I can drink minto ghost fluid with my minto GG cup.
Yay, yeah!
More powder, no less powder.
Melon soda rocks, I wish it was more available in the
States.
Yeah, for some reason like melon-y things, even though melon
is so popular, like I feel like the melon flavor, maybe
because like so often the taste is kind of done more
artificially doesn't I don't know why it's not so popular
here in the States what about mission oh oh it was a mission
nothing it's all watermelon yeah it's all watermelon
taste melons watermelon fake juice is just red sweet it's
not good It's not good.
Is it going to be me tomorrow on the plane?
No, I have work to do.
This is me usually on the plane.
I put on a movie and then I play solitaire while listening
or watching.
Orpal flavor.
Yeah, I love an orpal flavor.
I'm going to snort it before drinking it though when it
comes out.
I don't recommend.
In fact, I should discourage you from doing so.
Top Gun Maverick in Solitaire.
Yeah.
Since we are going on this old PC software trip, did you
ever use Enkarta?
Enkarta?
I don't think so.
It's odd.
Chatters, please don't snort.
No, it's not that.
What are you talking about?
Actually, it might be me.
That they're waiting on.
I wonder.
Can I get a red 7?
Oh, this is probably what...
Yeah, okay.
Well, that doesn't help me at all.
Not even a little bit.
Wikipedia.
Those are called encyclopedias, I think.
Those are called in a book.
Thank you, thank you.
Blessing your trip so you have chill flight buddies.
Today chat learns about books for the first time.
It was a digital encyclopedia.
Yeah, okay, okay.
M-O.
I remember playing Chips Challenge.
I need to play Chips Challenge now.
This is like everybody's thing.
Rodent's Revenge.
Everything is a...
Is a...
Alliteration.
Pipe Dream and Skip Free on Windows 95.
I've been getting A's in schools because of Encyclopedia
Britannica on CD.
No, there was one thing I played on CD.
CD.
Hold on, let me see if I can find it.
Oh my god, I found it.
I'm going to show you guys the thing that I played so much.
I don't think this is a game.
Did anyone else hop on my amazing human body?
Okay.
Chip-chasing?
No, no.
My amazing human body is where it was at.
Where you could like click on a certain body part.
What would Denza did that EXE flavor be?
Just straight pop rocks.
What in the world is that?
This was one of my favorite games when I was a little wisp.
Which, you know, it's kind of messed up now that I think
about it.
Because...
This game Loki made me hungry.
I get it!
I get it.
But it's kind of messed up because I was already dead when I
was playing this game.
I have no human body to learn about.
Actually, I've tried to stream this game before.
Um, I really want to.
Oh my god, I was an amazing series kid.
I thought I was the only one.
Yeah, this is the only one I played though.
I think I only played this because it had a skeleton onto
the cover.
I think that's why.
I'm...
Yeah, I think so.
he looks so goofy he sounds goofy too he's so friendly he is
in hindsight i don't like how seymour is looking at us our
eyes are up here bro enjoy your trivito bring back stories
please i will thank you nicholas i don't know if i'd let a
man named seymour skinless teach many kids is that his name
oh let seymour skinless teach your child about the human
body Seymour skinless
Oh my god Someone ring Seymour you know what you have to do
That's so messed up Suddenly Seymour's skinless
Oh wow They let him keep his eyes though but yeah that's
what I was hopping on oh yeah that was my game of choice
everybody skinless boneless oh no he had bones he was all
bones he only had bones oh I missed that dang it okay how'd
you know what I don't care it's my stream I can undo if I
want to.
I'm no, I'm no, no rules.
YouTube where we come to review our childhood memories
through a different perspective.
New true crime series has just dropped.
Seymour skinless the murderer.
No, he's a nice guy.
He's a good guy.
He didn't do it, your honor.
I really would like to end on a win.
It's been lost after loss after loss.
I would like to end on a win, please.
Seymour after a Mothman encounter would be problematic.
Would a guy be named Seymour?
That's literally his name.
Literally his name.
Wait.
I needed a...
I'm so hungry.
I want to go eat dinner.
I need a PB&J.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I need a black king, but then I need a red queen.
She's stuck there.
Dang.
Wait till we eat peanut butter.
Fizz now, thank you!
Thank you so much, Milo, Katuba.
Good luck on your march, Tramito.
Thank you for always keeping us in mind.
Us, our boys are so lucky to have you.
Wow, thank you.
We'll do a new game.
VTuber eat peanut butter.
For those who don't know, that was a request given to me
once on stream.
And it might be my favorite request.
But also very strange, no?
What an interesting individual.
That's funny.
It is pretty funny.
I'm glad you agree.
I eat peanut butter all the time.
I literally had a peanut butter lick yesterday.
That's what my mom calls them.
You just scoop up the peanut butter on a spoon.
Have you guys ever tried Japanese peanut butter?
Do not recommend.
Umamusame movie time.
Thanks for streaming.
Enjoy trip.
Thanks, Seymour.
Yeah, we'll be finishing up soon.
This might be...
This is LG, guys.
LG.
Last game.
It's not...
If you ever try Japanese peanut butter, it's so sad.
It's like a...
It's not peanut butter.
It's a peanut gel.
It's such a strange consistency.
And it's very sweet.
It's like, don't recommend it.
Last super chat.
Not weird one.
There's soft, low voices when singing.
Help me get to sleep faster from sleeping insomnia issues.
Truly, thank you.
I shall be waiting for my Mito Ghost Fluid Tubbs.
Good night.
Good night, Venu.
I'm glad I can help you sleep.
Weirdly, thank you so much for the pink.
Just want to wish you a good trip.
I know you'll be busy, but I hope you have fun as well.
Eat some good food in Japan.
so much mash but yeah I only learned I could eat peanut
butter this month it's so good I understand the hype yeah no
way why did you did you think you were allergic or something
is that why you didn't know before welcome to peak one of us
I'm trying not to jinx this but this I said LG and it ain't
looking so bad.
Kabo, thank you!
I don't know if you caught my super from last stream, but
lizard.
Thank you so much, Rana.
Okay, super, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Lizard.
Guys?
Oh, my God.
way I
need the six here though
no no just move
these around we'll just shuffle some things we can
we can we can Maybe.
We can, maybe.
Wait.
Did I mess up?
Wait, did I mess up?
Have a good trip, Minkus!
Thank you, Kevorn!
Thank you!
At least you get to hang out with Dancer too.
Love your silly ghosts.
Thank you!
The queen of hearts, what about it?
Wait, right-click the queen.
Oh, doesn't...
Wait, I think we need to switch...
Wait.
No.
No, no, no.
First over, super time.
Oh my god, continue to support you in the future.
Bloody Ocean, thank you so much.
Thank you.
I should have focused on this!
I-
Okay.
One moment, please.
No, it's not cheating.
It's- this is my own stream.
This is my own stream.
This is not cheating.
This is my stream.
And
on a win!
And on a win!
Yeah, baby!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Woohoo!
Thank you guys for joining me for Mind Sweeper and Pinball
and Solitaire.
Long time, Super Chatter.
First time, viewer.
Just want to say the thumbnail is so good.
I love thighs.
Miami's art is always amazing.
Also, that desktop is pure nostalgia.
Good luck on your trip.
Thanks, Miguel!
Long time, no see.
Thank you!
First time, viewer.
Duargo, thank you for the...
Guys, I love all!
Thank you for cozy, nostalgic, streaming, just chilling and
vibing like this.
This was really nice, especially after a long week.
Abba was relaxing for you.
twice.
Wishing you safe and happy travels to Japan.
I hope you get some yummy food and rest tonight.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Golden with the sauce.
Thank you.
Easy toes.
I'm going to go eat dinner now and finish packing.
Sexy, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I got a pack still.
Gapu, thank you!
Have a fun trip, Mito.
Thank you guys so much!
I'll see you, I'll see you next week, though.
Which, it's Friday.
So next week is not even that far away, you know?
Enjoy the trip.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
The pocket change.
Thank you.
Smash boot, thank you!
Smash boot!
Yeah.
Enjoy your meal, have a great trip.
Thank you.
I will hopefully next time I stream, I will not be so jet
lagged is the idea.
Give me a couple days to recover, right?
Thank you for hanging out with us.
Something good for dinner, safe travels.
Mammon, thank you.
Wow.
We see you.
Thank you.
One trip.
Jay, thank you so much for the pink.
I hope you have fun.
Thank you.
It was like a rainbow all of a sudden.
Thank you guys so much.
I can't see it today.
I can't look forward to Portal 2.
Oh, yeah.
I'm excited to see you guys watch.
Sorry I had to split it into two.
If I had more time, I would have recorded a second game for,
like, the second.
So, basically, I can stream.
Or I recover from jet lag.
Then I have a couple days that I can stream.
And then I'm busy.
And then...
Uh...
Yeah, I tried to do it as best as I could, but, you know...
Have a fun and safe trip, Minto.
Thank you!
Go eat the peanut butter.
I will.
Rogi, thank you so much for the five.
Get the safe travels.
Would you kindly?
Thank you guys so much.
I'll see you when I see you next, then, okay?
So...
And watch Portal 2.
It was really fun.
I'm big-brained.
Otsumi-to-me-to-it-a-shai.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Tarzan!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you, thank you, bye-bye!